I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense you're a super fit guy you
talked about food but I know you're
super into fitness - well I like fitness
because I've seen your Instagram videos
I see what you're up to you know that
was winning that wasn't gonna work I do
the work but that was actually when I'm
one that someone in my office said
listen why don't we show you at the gym
I'm like no no that's why it's my safe
space can you bleep can I just like you
know because there's some people on
Instagram they share when they brush
their teeth oh sure my kids are like oh
my gym but she's it like I said okay
just bow put up over like one quick
video you know none you know no you know
muscle shirt just like a you know fully
like head to toe flow no short cut off
no no no no no that's next one no that's
not an exit in the flashback coming
someone's coming so we did one right
just it was like a minute and it got
more hits and they hating my food videos
it was like when I looked at then I'm
like what my assistant it's time city I
told you I told you we should do this oh
my god
okay so then what was the conversation
oh then we said we did one a week and
was called workout Wednesday so we still
do it it still blows away anything I put
on you know people have been taking him
bacon and eggs and pork and all that
stuff and cheeseburgers and you know
food food sells food family and but
Fitness is really something I guess
because the juxtaposition of the
business chef and and working out you
wouldn't have it never used to be like
that
Yeah right the paradigm has really
changed you know this this saying never
trust a skinny chef is now you should
always trust a skinny chef because at
least the chef is maintaining a
lifestyle that can allow them to work in
a business they can show you how to eat
properly so you can stay within your
realm and yeah ever you want in a way
that's manageable yeah love that that's
why it is a paradigm shift instead of
saying like you have to be fat to be my
chef cuz that means the food is that
good likes now you don't give a [ __ ] no
it's well you have to care and it's no
reason I'm weed anyway why we just eat
in moderation self-respect yeah
self-respect and it's so if you respect
yourself enough you're gonna respect me
enough zactly and people are fascinated
and they're like really into it and like
you know they always asked me well how
do you do that I like well I mean I I
work all the time and they said when you
work I'm like five in the morning like
five honey I would never do that I'm
like exactly that's why that's why you
would never gonna do it so we have
you're saying it's not my saying but I
love it it's if you want to have
something you you've never had your
enough to do something you've never done
that's a very good thing so if you look
like [ __ ] and you've never pushed
yourself to work out well that's right
where you're gonna stay you know our
business you get up a fact I tell
everyone I speak to when I when I do a
lot of demos and interviews it's all
about this business is you're around
breakfast lunch and dinner everything is
free for a chef mmm
alcohol all the wine all the
socialization and you can take um people
come to you and you sit with them and
they come back and at the end of the day
your days over you want to have a train
it's a drink yeah that's a meet and it's
midnight or whatever it's just the most
provocative and dangerous at the same
time right so what you have to really
learn is that food is not the enemy amen
I agree I totally agree so keep talking
it is not the enemy there's no such
thing dieting is the enemy food is not
the enemy foods been around forever
those people have been eating great food
a full of fat they're in really good
shape that never exercise a day in their
life yeah you just have to find it and
you have to want to do it and if you
don't want to do it you're not gonna do
it it sounds simplistic but if you just
say well I dislike that I'm like okay
you know I'm I'm on a like I'm on a
fixed income well who fixed it you know
that's the sort of saying you have with
people they don't understand that you
have to really take some strides but you
can still eat what you want you have to
starve I completely and so making food
the enemy and making certain foods the
enemy is really bad versus all no car
then it's all steak then it's high fat
and it's no this then it's like no it's
like a balance
[Music]